whenever you send a search request to
Google the server actually does
something really really clever before
the server even knows what the search
results are it immediately returns the
header of the page which is what you see
here and this header is the same for all
users this allows the browser to start
processing the response and begin
constructing the Dom incrementally and
potentially even render the header then
once the search results are ready the
rest of the HTML arrives and the browser
parses that and displays the content as
you can see the browser doesn't have to
wait for all of the HTML to arrive
before processing and neither should
your server in fact returning partial
HTML can be a really nice performance
optimization incremental HTML delivery
very clever out of curiosity how did
that engineers at Google measure and
optimize performance of their pages
believe it or not they all use the same
tools chrome developer tools and mobile
debugging let me show you